I have tons of questions for you but I
think the place I have to start is I I
have a hard time calling you Rhys
because when I see you I think of Tracy
flick and Mel woods and June Carter and
Cheryl Strayed and all these iconic
fictional and real characters you've
played and I think what what that speaks
to for me is how deep you go into your
characters I feel like you've become
these people and I feel like L Woods and
Tracy flick are real people I kind of
feel like I know them
that's so cool to hear I think they're
real people too I get very invested so I
would love to hear about how you get
into these characters
what do you do to begin getting to know
the ones who never existed and also the
ones who did well I have to I think I
have to go backwards and say that I was
just such an Avid Reader as a little
girl so from my grandma taught me to
read when I was around five she was a
school teacher but she just picked me up
from school every single day and read to
me with lots of different voices of each
character so I learned to read in a way
that was very expressive and immersive
so as an early reader I just tore
through books and I was always looking
for really interesting character voices
so to me I always start with unique
character traits
um what makes this person tick right how
do they walk how do they behave where do
they grow up as a huge piece of it birth
order
um
socioeconomic status and then I start
working on Regional accents and
um layering things like how do they hold
their hands and how they walk and it's a
very private process for me I really
don't share with a lot of people I
didn't go to acting school
um so it's really just
comes from my imagination and I think
that's why I'm so interior about it it's
hard sometimes to tell directors what
choices I'm gonna make
um I try to be generous about it but I
also try to be as spontaneous as
possible because I think that's what
creates a real listening Behavior
between two actors part of the reason
I'm curious about this is we all have to
become people we're not in everyday life
and for me this is a huge part of
professionalism right just to say okay
I'm a shy introvert and I have to show
up on stage or in a podcast interview as
somebody a little different from that
and if I were a better actor it would
have taken me a lot less time to get
comfortable doing it so what what should
I have known oh well creating character
is just about how you want to present
yourself to the world right so with it
with this much authenticity as possible
so look you're doing fine Adam everybody
loves you but you know it's
I think how we show up
is is sort of a mixture of social norms
and then also what we want to expect of
ourselves and what is expected of us
inside the environment our work
environment so if you can hit that sweet
spot and it makes it feel authentic to
you and you can really show up at work
and feel seen and heard
um but also remember it's work right
you gotta show up you got to be
professional it's not therapy it's work
um I think that's the that's the sweet
spot so you're coming about authenticity
reminds me of the the classic work in
sociology and now bridged into
psychology around surface versus deep
acting
um and I'm sure you've heard these terms
before but when I think about surface
acting I think about basically putting
on a mask and trying to pretend to be
someone you're not and deep acting is
much more like method acting where I try
to feel internally what I want to
project to the outside world and I I'm
curious about how you how you adopt
those modes in your work um are you are
you fully on deep acting are there
moments when you're just trying to to
kind of portray the image but you're not
feeling it inside it was so interesting
I was talking to a acting student
yesterday and he was telling me he's
having a hard time accessing his
emotions and I said you know so much of
acting is just listening and behaving
how your character would behave and if
you know implicitly who your character
is
um you're gonna listen and respond the
way you should
but it comes from doing the work the
pre-work which is that's not surface
stuff it's really deep stuff if you grew
up in Beverly Hills and you grew up very
wealthy and you were able to have
spending money as a teenager you're
going to act different than a kid who
grew up in Omaha and with a single mom
and not knowing if you're going to get a
new pair of sneakers that year or the
next year and that you know if you don't
work hard and use every Advantage you're
never going to get ahead so those are
just two completely different
mentalities and if you know that about
your character walking in you can make
any kind of decision
it's really actually it makes so much
easier but I think you got to do the
pre-work it's it's about prep can you
walk me through what that pre-work
looked like what were some of the things
that you did to get to know Elwood's
character okay so L Woods that's
interesting so she grew up in an upper
middle class well probably upper class I
would say family and then she went to
um private high schools and so
I actually ended up going down to USC
and visiting A girlfriend of mine who
was in a sorority and lived in the
sorority for four years and I went down
every day and I sat with her during the
day while she was getting ready
um for going out and then I would also
have dinner with the girls or I would
take them out and we would talk about
um what were their life goals what did
they really want to accomplish what was
next for them and then the other thing
that I did just to get sort of the
posturing of the character is I went to
this fancy um department store in
Beverly Hills Neiman Marcus and I watch
women try on shoes I looked at their
nails I looked at the color of their
hair and then I would watch how they
would walk in certain different kinds of
shoes and how they held their hands when
they walk and how they spoke to people
and if it was clipped if it was kind it
was unkind and I don't know just all
those little micro behaviors add up to a
performance that is just from a place
that she felt confident but somehow she
was entering a new world and she got
kicked you know and suddenly her
confidence was shaken and she had
imposter syndrome even though she had
every reason to be there everybody was
making her feel like she didn't belong
and how you get that confidence back is
all up to you right so it came from
inside her last time we talked you said
sometimes it's helpful to think about
your own life as a movie and that helps
you figure out what store to tell what
speech to give what moment to hone in on
and you said something about how if you
were making my biopic which should never
be made it would open with me standing
on the end of the diving board shaking
yeah so I was wondering if if we could
resuscitate that and have you articulate
what was it that stood about stood out
about that moment why is this a useful
exercise and then I have some follow-up
questions on it
oh I mean it's so fun because I love
your book think again and when I was
reading it you talk about being a diver
and I thought that was such a great
visual metaphor too because how many
times do we feel like we're standing at
the edge of a high dive and you're like
I can't do it I can't do it
and there are people who would say well
screw it I'm gonna do it anyway
and there's people who go
I just can't and they'll turn around and
walk back down the ladder and off the
platform so I thought
that's the beginning of your movie to me
um but I think about Pinnacle moments in
people's lives and how we have all had
these moments of big decisions and
Crossroads and how they Define us and we
don't know what they are right until we
get to the full picture of what your
life Journey has been
um but I think
in terms of when I hear people talking
I'm like no that's your story
because everybody has to learn to tell
their story I don't care who you are
where you're from if you're a small
business owner you need to learn how to
tell your story whether it's on social
media to to for marketing you're gonna
have to tell your story and you tell it
in a compelling way and find the parts
that really resonate with people find
those touchstones that are like the
every person experience is it where you
grew up is it how much you love this
this project that you're so passionate
about why everybody wants to know why so
I think I'm real I get very invested in
helping people tell their stories in the
most effective way
one of the things I thought was so
profound about that was when you when
you pose this you know okay which kind
of person are you are you the person who
is gonna take the leap or are you gonna
be the person who climbs back down I'm
neither
I I was terrified to take the leap I was
afraid of heights I didn't want to crash
all over the pool it hurt I didn't want
to get lost in midair but I also
completely refused to get off the board
and I was not going to leave practice
until I did it and so I felt like I was
frozen in this point of ambivalence and
I didn't think of it until you described
this moment and painted the scene for me
um what what finally would get me to go
was the threat of having to get off the
board and walk down the ladder and I I
was so determined to not be that person
that it sort of forced me then to I
guess to be more courageous than I than
I was
wow well look at that the fear of regret
it's huge it's powerful yeah I was
afraid of regretting not doing it I was
afraid of letting my coach down and that
fear was stronger than the fear of you
know of flailing and smacking I like
that too do what you said you were gonna
do
you know and you said you were gonna do
it go do it what are those those moments
of I'm afraid of trying but I'm also
afraid of not trying look like for you I
mean every movie I've ever done is like
am I gonna be able to do this I mean the
ones that really come up for me or Walk
the Line because
playing a real person
I had to sing I had to perform
instruments that I had to learn how to
play every day I wanted to quit
every day I'd put in my stomach thinking
I'm going to be terrible
I'm gonna have to get up on this stage
in front of hundreds of people and I'm
gonna sound awful or I'm not gonna be
able to do it oh I tried everywhere I
called my lawyer I was like get me out
of this I told the director I can't do
it anymore
oh my gosh yes this is this is the role
that you won the Oscar for yes you
wanted to quit I wanted to quit seven
months of rehearsals and
um probably every day I mean I cried so
much during rehearsals
I was just scared
I'm scared about not being good enough
um
and then I realized I had to be the best
I could be I was never going to be June
Carter Cash I was never going to be a
perfect musician I was never going to
play the autoheart perfectly or the
guitar perfectly I was just going to
show up into the very best of my ability
and
there was a reason somebody thought I
could do it and I was not I was not
going to give up trying I'll always try
so
that first performance the first time we
did it Joaquin and I were together in we
were in Memphis
on this little stage oh my God it was
terrified there were 200 extras just
staring at us
and I thought I was gonna throw up
but I got out there I was like just do
it Reese just do it